he spent 16 years in prison after being
wrongly convicted of rape his accuser a
best-selling author is now apologizing
saying she's truly sorry but how do you
undo such a life-altering mistake here's
les trent
tears of joy as a man wrongly accused of
rape is exonerated after spending 16
years in prison anthony broadwater now
61 years old broke down in tears when he
heard the judge throw out the conviction
mr broadwater cannot get those 16 years
back his accuser was alice siebold
author of the lovely bones which was
made into a major movie starring mark
wahlberg it's going to be okay
my dad knows i'm here her rape at age 18
took place when she was a college
student in upstate new york years before
she became famous siebel says it
happened here in this 76 acre park
overlooking syracuse university where
she was a freshman months went by and
there was no arrest
then one day alice siebold was walking
down this street and she says she came
face to face with the man who attacked
her it was anthony broadwater he was
found guilty after siebold took the
stand and identified him as her rapist
the people that knew me and know my
character
they know that wasn't me doubts about
his guilt were raised when movie
producer timothy muchiante started
investigating the story as he prepared
to make a movie based on seabolt's
memoir about the rape called lucky
anyone who reads the transcript of the
trial and compares it to her book
there's quite a lot that's omitted that
a reader would would look at and say you
know this doesn't add up just like i did
c bold now 58 years old had nothing to
say as she walked her dog in san
francisco where she lives anything to
say to anthony broadwater
but on tuesday she issued a public
apology to broadwater in which she
acknowledged he had been wrongly accused
i am sorry most of all for the fact that
the life you could have led was unjustly
robbed from you and i know that no
apology can change what happened to you
and never will what do you think of that
apology if it's sincerely from my heart
i can accept it
the publisher of lucky says it has
ceased publication until they decide if
the book can be properly revised
because at first she didn't want to
uh correct her book
after all that
man that's crazy
man that is crazy i can't even uh
no i'm like
you know what i'ma tell you this
i'm not even gonna talk about the lady
but the dude that got out i was like i
accept your apologies
i got way too much
work to do on myself still
to be at the same level of that dude i
don't know what happened in prison
but if i'm
claiming my innocence
for 16 years
and i get out
and i get a thank you
and i'm sorry
and i pat on the back and onto my
way i know for a fact
i'm gonna need a whole lot of counseling
because the anger
that's gonna come out of that
bro i got anger now that i still gotta
deal with
from the past
and that stuff didn't happen to me
i'm coming out after 16 years finally
it's it is a relief
it is a relief
about that time you lost everything
there's no way for you to get it back
no
way can't get your work back
you can't get your livelihood
some family [ __ ] distance himself
from you
some friends
oh
there's too much anger
like right now i'm watching this story
and it's not happening to me and i'm
angry
so if it happened to me i don't even
know what i would have done yeah there's
a phenomenon that happens to people who
get sent to prison unjustly and spend
lots of time there and a lot of them
come up very
forgiving
generally when they're out of prison and
people can't understand it because
they're saying if it was me i'd feel
this way or i'd feel that way but you
don't know what it feels like to have 16
20 years of your life robbed and stuck
in this cell
you don't know
so you don't know what goes through your
mind i can assure you
that from what i read up on what all
them seem to say is like initially i was
just angry and i was in disbelief there
was a lot of denial like i'm going to
get out of here i know how to do this
they're going to fix this
and as that realization sets in you
understand how unjustly done you are
then that anger sits in
right and you got a lot of rage
but the thing about anger and rage is
that when you're in a cell and all you
have is time alone with your own
thoughts it's very hard to be angry for
decades and decades
hard because that [ __ ] will kill you
that oh that'll end your life early
so for a lot of them forgiveness is also
a means of survival it's a way for them
to be able to be good with themselves
and so when i hear what this man has to
say i think it's unbelievably
wonderful that he's able to find that
not for her but for himself
because to hold on to that anger and
that grudge breath that shit'll tense up
your whole body that should have aged
you fast
resentment will age you fast
and so i'm happy for him
so that he could move forward with his
life and i hope he gets the restitution
he deserves because they stole 16 years
of his life
and i think
the kind of character that he displayed
i respect a lot it's some i want to be
able to emulate
now that being said
if i encounter the woman who
who accused me when i was in the
military i would superman punch her in
the face
me first
forgiveness is fantastic i ain't there
yet if i see that woman i hope i get to
drop kick her i'm not polite test me but
i hope i can get to the place where he
said good on him
secondly for the lady
that little apology note that she wrote
i'm sorry that 16 years of your life
were robbed from you [ __ ] you robbed
him it's not like somebody else did that
you identified him you got understand
and you said it's definitely him
and then
you wrote a book and like listen
sometimes people misremember stuff
trauma like i could i could
justify a lot if i was to give you a lot
of leeway
then you write a book
and omit a bunch of details that might
have actually shown his incident
innocence meaning you knew to not put
that [ __ ] in because you knew it didn't
make your story credible now i got a
problem
unfortunately we exist in a world where
people can make false
allegations against people they can say
whatever they want and the kind of
repercussions they face are minimal
minuscule
and folks are just supposed to accept
that hey man this is the way of justice
seems to work you know sometimes people
go to jail and you could be lying or
omitting facts or being extremely
disingenuous or all this stuff and no
one's gonna be held accountable maybe
the state pays out some tax dollars so
so the taxpayers
have to pay for it
to me that's wrong that's where my
disappointment in this whole thing lies
but as for the man i'm i'm i'm happy for
him if he really isn't that place that
he claims to be and i respect that
[ __ ] i thought i was pissed off now
like like i said i wish i was at this at
this point i wish i had what he has i
wish i i wish i was at that that that
moment
that point in my life where i could do
what he did because to me it's
phenomenal
do you remember years ago when you used
to cover these stories how angry and
yelling that would be remember when i
was how angry i was yelling i would be
back then you weren't as mad
you weren't
you remember me
i would lose my mind over stories like
this right why because that's very
tender
yeah
and so
knowing that
i'm here today much more chill about
things because i've had to let a lot of
[ __ ] go
and i'm telling you that [ __ ] ages you
and you sit there with resentment it
keeps you up at night you can't hold on
to that forever you got to let that [ __ ]
go i know but there's a lot of yeah i'm
working on it but there's a yeah but
that's me that's just that's just what i
know and i i i know what you're saying
there's a lot of [ __ ] that yeah i'm
working on some [ __ ]
but
um
yeah
i can hold on to things for a long
long
long time yep
i hold grudges for a long time
long ass time yeah man
if i see you in the streets
it's on site exactly irrespective
whether or not they look fresh and fit
it's on site
still working
keep working on it man
anyways that's it for today's video let
us know what you think in the comments
below